Speaker 1: I want to talk about the latest grift
scam from the Republican Party. There's a very
good article in Truthout about this. Trump and
Republicans are raking in millions of dollars with
these fascist fundraising emails. Now, many of you
have written to me about these emails. Many in our
audience, they don't even know how they ended up
on the Republican email list and on Trump's email
list. Truth Out's report is is it's mind blowing.
Trump remains the highest totaling fundraiser
in the Republican Party. Experts say the
fundraising emails fueling his political ambitions
increasingly echo conspiracy theories and employ
fascist rhetoric, that's true. I've seen him.
Trump's fundraising emails helped generate three
hundred and seventy eight million dollars in 2020,
and there's 110 million in Trump's war chest as
of a couple of months ago. That's more than what's
been reported by the RNC and DNC combined. The
fundraising success suggests Trump's messaging
resonates with many Republicans. Trump's deceptive
fundraising emails are not just obnoxious.
If you're a supporter, subscribe to Trump's
email list, you're told. Sinister forces
are destroying a nation that rightfully
belongs to patriots like you. Only Trump can
save America from humiliation. This is classic
20th century rhetoric. We don't have to say Hitler
because it's really more like Mussolini. It's
really more more like others. Some appeals
appear to operate like a sweepstakes letting you
meet Trump in person or go to a top secret rally.
Now we've already talked before about how many
of these things Trump's not there. There was one
promoted as like, have lunch with Trump, but only
Lindsey Graham was going to be there. They also
use language like Trump's inner friend circle,
where a select few will be exposed to confidential
information he won't trust other people
with. And that is similar to the QAnon stuff.
It's similar to these, you know, fights
against elite cabals and so on and so forth.
This is classic. This is a clinic in
reactionary fear mongering. We live in a society
where so many people just freely will turn money
over to rich people that openly despise them.
And that is what we are seeing here. This is the
giving culture where these reactionaries who Trump
has spent listen, guys, we've said it before.
Trump is a rich guy from New York, has spent
his life trying to be kept away from the people
that make up the bulk of his base, the people
giving the small dollar donations because that's
all that they can afford at the end of the day.
And it is what his campaign has been built on.
Trump doesn't like these people, but he will grift
them out of every last dollar. The emails are
also really a study into cults, and I know I've
said this before, but I've recently been reading
about the Charles Manson cult. And when you read
the interviews that the cult members would give
to law enforcement when it all kind of fell apart,
the language and the demeanor and the tone is
so similar to that which we hear from Trump
supporters today. And you know, as I've
said before, I don't want anyone getting
scammed. I don't want I don't want anyone
getting scammed. And at the same time,
at what point do you say these people are
determined to be scammed? They're determined
to give Trump the money. They're falling for
the fascistic rhetoric they're doing all of it.
I don't know. I don't know at what point we say we
just kind of can't protect these people anymore.
I don't know when we get there, but it
seems like we're probably pretty close